okay so rings of Power episode 6 is now
here and the entry is filled with Easter
eggs hidden details and a big ending
that we're gonna be breaking down in
this video the show has been very hit
and miss but just when I think it
couldn't get any Dumber you come back
and completely redeem yourself does it
save the series for us we'll get into it
but I definitely feel like this is a big
step in the right direction though it
does play fast and loose with a lot of
the cannon this is easily the most
focused episode so far with us just
getting the orondia and Galadriel story
lines instead of all the other side
characters like Kevin I don't bloody
care man anyway crap puns aside the
entry ends with a creation of Mount Doom
this is something we've been speculating
would happen and it's very much a pompe
level event for the people of Middle
Earth Adar has wanted to create a way
for the Orcs to be able to thrive during
the day and last week he talked about
how he wanted to destroy the Sun the
mountain will blanket the clouds with
Ash and make it a land of Eternal
Darkness so that the Orcs can move about
whenever they like as discussed in the
original Trilogy the very airy there is
poisonous due to the Ash and I think
everyone is gonna have to leave because
it's completely lost while dragons are
fully forming the blade and next to the
shrine of Sauron he twists the key to
release water which then travels through
the trenches into the lava beneath the
mountain it was nice seeing the plan all
come together and this will of course
give Sauron a way to create the one ring
this is very much an opposite to the
forge which we know is being built by
Keller Brembo and the elves I'm guessing
that the finale will have a seed in
which Sauron creates the ring and on the
opposite side of this we will see his
Keller brimbo starts to create the
others it's being said throughout the
season that Adidas plan is to give the
Orcs a home for them to live in and he
finally accomplishes this making him the
good guy I guess now he gives a really
rousing speech in the opening in which
he calls them all brothers and sisters
that have had to endure the daylight
brought a tear to my eye and you know
what I was like yeah [ __ ] them up I'm up
you could say I adore him if you put a
bit of a Leslie Phillips on that it
works
yeah
now this ending is foreshadowed in the
opening shot of the entry with a doll
running his hands through the dirt and
he says New Life in defiance of death he
plants some seeds in orondia later gives
him to Bronwyn which we learn as an
Elvish tradition that they carry out
before a battle in the end this land
will very much belong to Sauron and
Mount Doom secures that this will no
longer be where men feel free to tread
in the books the Madden actually
responded to his presence and after his
defeat it lay dormant until the Rings
start to make its way back upon his
defeat the volcano erupted violently
once more and it happening here shows
that the heroes have already lost when
the waves come crashing down I also
wonder if this might have a ripple
effect in which the oceans fled numenor
I think were too early in the timeline
for that to be happening the episode has
a lot of action in it and because of
this there's not that much stuff to
break down Easter eggs wise but we will
be going through it all if you enjoy the
video please hit the thumbs up button
and also don't forget to subscribe for
videos like this every day by the way
huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into rings of power
[Music]
monologue that would make William
Wallace head off we watch as the Orcs
storm the tower I got a lot of Helms The
Vibes here with the design of the area
looking similar to the offshoot of the
location they even have a pathway up and
the Orcs carry a battering ram similar
to that movie as predicted arondia ends
up using the tower to kill them and it
brings down the entire structure on them
whilst my mind busts out some Kung Fu to
lock them inside Bronwyn returns to the
village with a people and because of
this early attack a door ends up using
decoys in order to spare his Orcs he
swarms the village with men in orc
uniforms and they realize that they've
been forced to fight amongst themselves
in order to whittle down their numbers
how they work together they probably
could have defeated the Orcs but divided
they fall I've always thought that
Tolkien originally wanted to show that
people from all walks of life can work
together to defeat evil and this is why
Lord of the Rings was very much about
the elves dwarves men and Hobbits coming
together as one it's only once the
numenorians arrive at things finally
start to feel like they're on the up and
up and we weaker to them making their
voyage across the sea ACL gets up to
sweep the stables and he ends up eating
an apple typically in fiction apples are
supposed to represent knowledge and
wisdom but a seal door ends up throwing
this into the sea might be reaching but
it could be symbolizing his lack of it
which is then filled in by everyone's
favorite character Galadriel she talks
about using her Elvish eyes to see the
shoreline and this is something that
we've seen Legolas and elrond doing the
sealdah has been punished to sweep the
stables and this lack of power could be
why he holds another ring so tightly he
says that he wanted to escape numenor
because the true numenor trumanore no
longer exists however Galadriel says
that he carries it within him his father
would of course gone to become the king
and asildo would carry the blood of the
numenorians in him which would be passed
on to Aragorn his mother is brought up
several times in this episode and there
are theories that she might be the voice
that he constantly keeps hearing I
actually think that it's more likely
Sauron or a dark force masquerading as
him in order to manipulate the character
we learn that she drowned and the source
material itself doesn't really touch
upon her on Muriel's map we watch as she
outlines the plan I believe this text is
written in numenorians in Darwin which
was their language Captain Obvious there
but I don't know how they know a big
attack is coming in the village but as
soon as they hit the coast they just go
mental and start pegging it out there
maybe we hadn't sat around for 10 days
preparing you wouldn't have to do this
but never mind now we could do a rondier
trying to destroy the blade but he fails
to do it this is obviously meant to be
similar to the ring and how Gimli tried
to break it at the fellowship Council he
goes to hide it but hey he could have
picked somewhere better mate big crap
but moving on and my guess is that it
will be dropped in about Doom but Theo
ends up spying on him they prepare for
the fight in the daylight orondia
promises to become Theo's new stepdad
and whether that's gonna happen or not
remains to be seen the sunset in the
battle brings a new meaning to the
phrase eye for an eye and all in all I
did really enjoy this scene after six
hours of plotting and next position it
felt nice to get something where it felt
there were real Stakes to it and I know
and I know everyone's gonna be like you
only like action you're so stupid but it
is nice once in a while just to break
things up you know add some Dynamics now
it's gory filled with Home Alone traps
and it has a great One-Shot take in it
when the trick is revealed the Orcs fire
from the trees and they hit Bronwyn
before they storm The Tavern Jade
Ralphie also returns as an Orc which we
get confirmed by the credits and not
only has he played one and died in this
series but he's also an actor that's
appeared as one in The Lord of the Rings
trilogy he also played Nori the dwarf
and Peter Jackson's Hobbit films and I
hope we get him back every single
episode it's great to see him constantly
popping up and hide your wife hide your
kids because the Orcs cut through them
to make a point and it's all in service
of getting the blade Theo gives it to
save his mother and reveals it's hidden
under a slab I thought I thought you
said no one would ever find it you
[ __ ] idiot though what's all this is
going on we watched the Cavalry rolling
in with Adriel and it's moments like
this where you realize why this is the
most expensive show ever made they still
in the village and it reminded me a lot
of the Cavalry descending on Helms Deep
In The Two Towers obviously Amazon have
purposely pulled from the Jackson movies
as much as possible because they know
that's what general audiences relate to
the most I'll probably get a lot of
dislikes of saying I enjoyed this scene
but I thought the horse stunt work was
really well put together especially with
collaterals swinging around on hers
whilst beheading Orcs El India is saved
by Hal branwell ceciled or rushes to his
side and something similar would happen
with him going to his father after he
struck down by Sauron Adara is captured
and we discover that he was one of the
elves used to create the very first Orcs
Adar translates the father and he sees
himself very much as one to the race the
book of lost Tales detailed at morgoth
bred them from the Heats and slimes of
the earth however this has been pretty
much cast to the side with even Tolkien
himself clearly stating that morgoth
couldn't create life during the first
years of the Lambs it said that the
elves were kidnapped been tortured till
they became the very first Orcs Adar
says that he killed Sauron but we know
that can't be the case because of what
comes next in the timeline I was
speaking with our editor Matt about this
and he was questioning whether Adar is
Sarah now and some of the Highlander
it's like killing Sauron makes you
become Sauron it would pick the fans off
so much if this was the case and do the
name father and stuff I think it's more
just along the lines of exactly how it's
presented here in the name Sauron has
triggered him before and instead I think
he views himself as carrying his message
rather than actually becoming him Sauron
is like the in the Unseen World
currently which once more gets name
dropped we discovered in episode 1 that
the Orcs were experimenting with a way
to access this and get flashes of it in
a doze monologue he tortured Orcs trying
to access it I think we also see some
Stone carvings of what looks like a
balrog's head Adar was complicit in
killing what he refers to his children
all in the sacrifice of sauron's goals
he says that he killed him for this but
again I don't think it's true and that
kind of takes us in a theater
so how Brown clearly knows a dog and he
almost kills him out in the woods upon
going to exit the barn Adar asks him who
he is but he refuses to answer another
most popular Theory at the moment is
that he's Sauron and if a dog killed the
dark lord then it makes sense that he'd
have this Vendetta against him he has
whispered in pharazone's yeah similar
what Sauron did and one of his first
lines was about how appearances can be
deceptive now this might be the case
with him masquerading as the king
because it's clear no one knows who he
is a theories that he's Theo's father
are out the window and he could just be
a thief who took the sigil or perhaps
even the dark lord himself in the book
Sauron appeared as Anatole AKA The Lord
of gifts and under this guy she
pretended to be a positive figure could
very much be the case here though I am
still second guessing this but anyway
that's in a theater
I don't really think he's Sauron but I
thought I just discuss it in a few times
he's probably just a normal guy probably
a nice guy seems alright
I would notice is that morgoth's success
has become her mirror I think this is
just the scriptwriters trying to do a
play on galadriel's mirror which I don't
know if it lands anyway we get a even
completely on when we discover that Hal
brand it definitely isn't Theo's father
Muriel introduces him to lead them but
the guy isn't someone I don't think
people want in charge he's a thief
scoundrel and seems like he's been
slaughtered into being in charge without
an actual vote which could lead to him
crashing the economy but we won't get
into that now Rodney gives the bite back
to Theo and tells him to find a way to
toss it into the sea but he realizes
it's been one big bait and switch and
that it's a tool just like he is I'll
end you'll give some words to his father
about becoming one with a horse and I
knew I knew a horse once had had white
kids so never mind now we ended with a
mountain being created and the land
being blanket in the ash of Doom after
waldrick starts the fire up that ends
the episode and I'm sure you can tell
from the breakdown that I enjoyed this
entry way more than one what's come
before there wasn't really any messing
around and I think just having a clear
focus on a select group of characters
really really helped rather than jumping
back and forth between characters
dropping Exposition we saw as we got to
follow a small group as they fought
through the highs and lows of Middle
Earth now obviously you do need setup
but I think the series has spent way too
much time in that mode so it's nice to
finally get some payoff happy to say it
didn't disappoint and it sets up a lot
of things for next time I'm guessing
that will of course see the orc Uprising
as the men try and survive the landscape
being changed but beyond that they can
tie several things into it the half vets
are of course pushing their Caravan and
I think they'll see the eruption and
potentially be caught in it last episode
we watched as they crossed what I
believe of the Dead marshes so there is
potential that they're in the area if we
can also get the fall of numeral I think
that would be big too so yeah lots of
things to look forward to in the next
two episodes hopefully it steers the
shift back on track and you know if they
end on a high note I think I'll be a lot
more forgiving of what's come before
anyway I'd love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we are in a competition right now
and giving away three copies of Thor 11
thunder on the 15th of October and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe the notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on Twitter at heavy spoilers you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our Brighton of She-Hulk
or maybe not maybe go watch House of the
Dragon which will be linked on the
screen right now by the way thanks for
singing through the video having more
let's see you next time take care peace